hi i'm anthony bouchon developer
advocate at google and welcome to gke
essentials
[Music]
did you know that gke clusters can scale
up to 15 000 nodes
owning a cluster with that sheer scale
is hard for me to comprehend at times
but let's dive into it together
this video is the first part of a
two-part introduction to building
large-scale gke clusters
over the course of these videos we'll
talk at a high level around two key
areas
one why you might consider building
clusters with thousands of nodes
and two what considerations you should
account for when designing clusters to
be able to scale
kubernetes especially shines for those
of you looking to build a platform to
run your company's workload
it gives you a means for abstracting
away infrastructure no need to directly
deploy workloads to a specific machine
rather you deploy it to the cluster and
kubernetes will make sure it runs
somewhere
it also gives you declarative apis that
codify a workload's characteristics and
enforces that behavior
you can even extend these apis with your
own definitions of how workloads should
run
this is why one of the founders of
kubernetes went as far as calling the
open source technology a platform for
building platforms
now these platforms that you build could
be home to a set of large resource
intensive workloads such as batch
processing or machine learning
or they could also be the generalized
way in which you enable developers to
access infrastructure for their various
and potentially differing workloads
it should be noted that when you're
building multi-tenant clusters the
harder isolation or stronger boundaries
that you require between these workloads
the more likely it is you should
consider using multiple smaller clusters
nevertheless using fewer large-scale
clusters in some of these cases can help
in a handful of ways
one they can help you minimize the
number of clusters you have to actively
manage
this helps with problems like
configuration drift across clusters or
juggling multiple concurrent upgrade
cycles
two you can more easily handle resource
spikes
if you're building a platform you may
have many different teams as users each
with their own plans for rolling out
their own workloads to the platform or
scaling up their workloads
building a cluster that can scale to
larger sizes can help absorb these
varying demands concurrently
[Music]
and finally for those of you building
specialized platforms for batch
processing or machine learning building
a large-scale cluster brings the
simplicity of the kubernetes api to
these complex performance intensive
workloads
even if you're not looking to build a
cluster that's 15 000 node you can still
realize these benefits by building a
cluster that can scale to house large
amounts of resources so let's talk about
considerations for designing and
building a large scale cluster like this
when it comes down to it as a platform
builder you are providing a contract to
your end users and their workload
you ask them to package their workload
in a container with assurances that your
platform will run that workload reliably
so at the heart of building large-scale
clusters is not just the concept of
adding more nodes or more pods but
rather figuring out how to maintain your
cluster reliability when doing so
of course we can't cover every single
design consideration for large-scale
clusters in this episode but let's dive
into where you should start thinking
it's important to think of cluster
design across two categories
they are the considerations at the
greater kubernetes level which revolves
around the kubernetes api and their
objects such as pods services name
spaces
and these are not specific or limited to
any one infrastructure provider
then there are considerations at the gke
level which include google cloud
resources such as vpcs
underlying compute storage and gke
specific features to help tune your
cluster to reach these larger sizes
we'll actually cover the google cloud
and gke parts in part 2 of this series
so let's cover the kubernetes resources
first
kubernetes scalability is defined by the
special interest group focused on
scalability as a multi-dimensional
envelope
within this envelope your cluster will
work and do so reliably
this envelope has configuration
limitations at various dimensions it
could be the number of pods number of
name spaces number of secrets
so when designing a cluster for large
scale it helps to understand and start
thinking about how your cluster will fit
within this envelope
now i definitely don't work with
multi-dimensional envelopes on a
day-to-day basis so let's actually talk
a little bit about how an envelope like
this works
in the envelope of kubernetes
scalability dimensions are not always
independent of one another
an example in kubernetes we have the
ability to run 110 pods per node we're
also able to run thousands of nodes in a
given cluster
but to do both at the same time
this likely would result in an
unreliable cluster as we are stretching
multiple dimensions too far
pods per node nodes and total pods in
the cluster in a scenario like this
knowing how these dimensions relate to
one another can help you make
adjustments like changing the maximum
number of pods per node in your cluster
in gke for these large scale clusters we
generally recommend considering fewer
pods per node than the maximum
a good starting benchmark we've seen
with successful users is roughly 30 pods
per node the next thing to consider is
scaling to the maximum in any one
direction can taper your ability to
scale across the other dimension
so it's important to think about what
resources your platform could push to
the limit
a highly specialized cluster to serve as
a batch processing platform for example
i have numerous pods being created and
deleted at the same time depending on
the status of jobs that are running and
this will affect podchurn
a multi-tenant enterprise platform might
have hundreds of workloads across
hundreds of teams each isolated to their
own set of namespaces
it's important to plan around what is
most critical to make your platform on
kubernetes work for your users and to
test those dimensions one at a time and
independently
finally all the resources your platform
uses in kubernetes share an upper bound
which is set by the underlying state
system for kubernetes at cd
this not only includes the kubernetes
objects you're probably familiar with
deployments secrets stateful sets etc
but also the resources that are created
using custom resource definitions
in fact many open source technologies
built atop kubernetes utilize this to
persist their own objects to the
kubernetes control plane that their own
set of controllers interact with
all of these objects are subject to
scd's underlying limitations such as 800
megabytes per object type
and the overall total storage of etcd
given this we recommend understanding
the implications of what is actually
getting created in your cluster
for example the built-in kubernetes job
resource requires certain configurations
to ensure that resources are cleaned up
upon completion
custom resources can also expand one
resource into several others such as
pipeline runs in tecton
these are not bad things if you need to
run kubernetes jobs or custom resources
like what technon provides great
but it's important to know their
behavior when building a platform for
your end users
now that we've taken a high-level
walk-through of kubernetes scalability
we'll need to cover how to design around
gke features and google cloud
infrastructure to support these
large-scale clusters which we'll cover
in part two in the meantime take a look
at these resources to better understand
the kubernetes scalability dimensions
that we discussed today thank you for
your time and we will see you on the
next episode part two in gke essentials
[Music]
you